bonjour bienvenue dans la troisième
saison de ses caches ces caches que vous
pouvez regarder encore s'en passe
sanitaires
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la réserve fédérale américaine
et de la banque centrale européenne
bonjour mira bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous et bienvenue dans ces caches la
dernière réunion du conseil de la
réserve fédérale américaine a livré ses
conclusions c'est un peu fou pour
l'instant mais ça se précise la fed
pourrait bien fermer le robinet la
majorité de ses membres se disent
favorables au taps ring une réduction
des achats d'actifs on en parlera en
deuxième partie avec un autre invité à
l'économiste et directeur du cabinet
rincon pierre bentata est à peine l
annonce de la fed de publier
déstabilisation des marchés mondiaux
c'est le tiroir cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
depuis juin 2020 et les premiers impacts
du coup vite sur l'économie la fed n'a
pas lésiné sur l'injection de mener sur
les marchés près de 120 milliards de
dollars par mois afin que la bourse
américaine et par ricochet les bourses
mondiales ne s'effondre pas des achats
d'actifs massifs qui pourraient bientôt
se réduire à en croire le compte rendu
de la dernière réunion de la fed fin
juillet ce qu'on appelle les minutes 13
membres du comité de la réserve fédérale
sur dix huit seraient favorables à un tp
bing une réduction progressive de
l'achat d'actifs sur les marchés sept
membres de plus qu'au mois de mars
dernier en bref la fête pourrait bientôt
enfin d'ici 2023 fermer un peu peut-être
beaucoup les robinet d'argent frais il
faut dire et on en a déjà parlé
plusieurs fois ici que le cosy devra
démontrer plus que jamais une
déconnexion flagrante entre des marchés
soutenus comme jamais par les banques
centrales et l'économie réelle bien mal
en point des marchés qui ont d'ailleurs
assez mal accueilli cette nouvelle les
indices boursiers ont tous clôturé à la
baisse après la publication de ce compte
rendu de la fed reste à savoir si la fed
rejoindra les actes à la parole et si
les marchés pour un jour se passer des
aides massives des banques centrales aux
divier la fête n'est pas vraiment
précise elle a dit dans un premier temps
la croissance repart donc plus besoin de
faire tourner la planche à billets comme
ça et puis le dit tout de même qu'elle
surveillera de près l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire est ce que la fed
finalement en vallée jusqu'au bout non
bien sûr que non et achète on n'est pas
dans le premier dans la première fois
c'est à dire que souvenez vous de ce qui
s'est passé fin 2018 fin 2018 monsieur
peau elle nous explique que ça y est on
a beaucoup de croissance que le taux
d'intérêt normal normative cc3 et demi
pour cent on est à deux et demi à ce
moment là et ces trois et demi pour cent
parce que c'est c'est soutenable pour
une économie qui va tellement bien et
qui
et qui croient donc à ce moment là les
marchés
tombe ton d'une vingtaine de pourcents
sur le sur les indices américains sur
les indices actions américains la halle
et aux stands on monte au-dessus de 3 et
et là vous voyez monsieur powell qui
revient quelques semaines seulement plus
tard pour nous dire que finalement on
avait dû mal comprendre où il s'était
mal exprimé où
il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas et donc bien sûr il recommencer à
acheter massivement des obligations pour
faire baisser les taux et il rouvre est
la planche à billets donc voyez que
finalement aujourd'hui les banques
centrales sont marc est dépendante et
non plus date indépendante c'est-à-dire
qu'elles ne dépendent plus des chiffres
économiques elles dépendent des marchés
c'est les marchés qui ont la main
aujourd'hui les marchés disent à chaque
fois qu'ils à ce genre de déclarations
il secoue un peu et et et regarde ce
qu'ils tombent et ce qui tombe c'est
monsieur powell systématiquement en
disant non nous avons nous avons du mal
se comprendre pourquoi il dit ça tout
simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans un tel état d'avancement en termes
de dette et en terme de ce que doit
aujourd'hui
m comme nouvelles dettes en face d'un
déficit budgétaire abyssal
et en est obligé de m et donc la banque
centrale il faut qu'elles achètent ses
obligations
et comme il faut qu'elles achètent ses
eh bien figurez-vous que elle n'a pas le
choix et donc tout ça c'est du cedus et
de la communication c'est la
communication pour essayer de freiner un
petit peu les choses c'est de la
communication pour maintenir en état les
les marchés et un semblant d'activité
économique et mais ça n'est pas une
réelle volonté de leur part pour la
bonne et simple raison qu'ils ne peuvent
pas revenir en arrière donc nous sommes
dans une dans une période de com alors
vous on l'a vu d'ailleurs beaucoup de
fois au japon au japon où vous aviez
monsieur qu rodaki arrivé tout sourire
la télé en vous expliquant qu'il allait
changer de politique monétaire et qui
trois jours plus tard revenait à la télé
en disant non on s'est mal compris et
qui recommençait là même la même planche
à billets et les mêmes achats donc
aujourd'hui on est dans quelque chose
qui ne peut pas être modifiée vous êtes
obligés d'en remettre à chaque fois un
petit peu plus et donc monsieur powell
peut bien dire ce qu'il veut en fait la
réalité est tout le contraire
olivier merci on se retrouve tout de
suite pour la deuxième partie de cette
émission
est notre invité à pierre bentata vient
de nous rejoindre et les économistes et
directeur et président du cabinet à
rincon pierre bentata bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors on vient de le
dire à la fête fait entendre qu'elle
compte réduire son programme d'achat
d'actifs est ce que selon vous c'est le
bon moment
c'est pas tant une question de timing
c'est le moment de communiquer là dessus
pour montrer que on entre dans la phase
que que des économistes attendait au
tout début de la crise qui est une phase
inflationnistes alors on a beaucoup
d'économistes aujourd'hui qui nous
disent que c'est pas le cas mais quand
vous regardez les indicateurs des
matières premières quand vous regardez
le logement quand vous regardez les
problèmes qu'on a notamment sur
l'augmentation du coût des semi
conducteurs tout ça c'est lié au fait
qu'on a injecté beaucoup de monnaie
qu'en même temps l'économie réelle elle
suit pas donc c'est le moment de
communiquer en disant grosso modo de
faire comprendre à tout le monde dont
cette politique à elle pose des
problèmes on est en train de mettre
l'économie réelle à risque on la soumet
vraiment un risque important mais dans
le même temps comme l'a dit olivier
avant ça veut pas dire que ça va être
fait très souvent et c'est à peu près le
seul domaine d'ailleurs en économie vous
avez ça quand les banques centrales
elles communiquent les économistes font
de l'analyse sémantique on fait
l'analyse du langage on essaye de
comprendre ce qui va ce qui va vraiment
être dit ce qui va être fait quelles
sont les idées qui sont cachés derrière
les formulations donc on sait que c'est
un jeu qui est vraiment un jeu de
communication et là l'objectif c'est
vraiment de dire on n'en dans la phase
inflationnistes 90 dans une phase qui
est problématique le concret nier et que
en même temps on a essayé de se
convaincre qu'il n'aurait pas lieu donc
c'est le moment où il va falloir que
certaines choses se passent mais
évidemment on va pas couper les robinets
d'un coup parce que c'est d'abord
impossible et là on ferait s'effondrer
l'économie puisque c'est cette grande
phase inflationnistes cette phase en
tout cas d'augmentation de la masse
monétaire qui dure maintenant depuis
presque deux ans elle a créé une bulle
très importante sur le marché financier
et elle a favorisé l'apparition de
zombies qui ne peuvent plus tenir sans
ça
alors vous allez voir le graphique
concrètement la fed a acheté 120
milliards de dollars d'actifs par mois
depuis juin 2001 depuis plus d'un an
olivier ses normes et ses achats
d'actifs ce sont des stimulants visant à
soutenir une croissance positive sans
eux comment ferait finalement les états
unis n'ont alors je vais je vais
remettre un peu les choses en place ces
120 milliards ne sont pas là pour
stimuler l'économie ces 120 milliards
sont là pour stimuler la bourse les
uniquement la bourse c'est à dire et
maintenir les taux d'intérêts en bas ils
sont pas là pour cette vous pouvez faire
autant de quantitative easing que vous
voulez ça ne relancera pas l'économie
c'est pas un booster d'économie c'est
pas pour ça que lvmh ou microsoft ou
google vont vendre plus donc ça n'a rien
à voir avec une une économie je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure les banques centrales
aujourd'hui son market dépendantes et
uniquement marque est dépendant donc si
elles ne veulent pas aujourd'hui réduire
leurs achats c'est tout simplement parce
que elles savent très bien que le jour
où elle annonce seront réellement une
réduction de leurs achats les marchés
vont s'effondrer et que là il faudra y
revenir et on l'a vu je vous ai dit en
fin 2008 de 8,18 où on a vu très bien
que ce n'était pas tenable les marchés
l'ont signalé et il joue avec ça les
marchés c'est-à-dire qu'ils savent très
bien qu'ils ont le pouvoir au final et
que s'ils veulent il secoue un peu et
que la banque centrale va arriver au
grand galop pour les aider pour soutenir
la bourse et uniquement la bourse donc
l'activité n'a rien à voir là dedans 1
on le sait depuis quand même maintenant
12 ans que le quantitative easing ne
sert à rien pour relancer l'activité
j'espère que tout le monde s'en est
aperçu et que tout le monde en est
conscient maintenant en revanche ça crée
des bulles ça y'a pas de problème ça
crée des bulles et surtout ce qu'ils
veulent faire c'est maintenir les taux
bas pour la bonne et simple raison que
les états doivent émettre une somme
d'obligations qui est juste ahurissant
tu avec toutes les dispositions qu'ils
ont prises pour soi disant aider
l'économie et donc ils doivent émettre
des des montants ahurissant je vous dis
que ce soit en europe ou que ce soit aux
états unis et que pour ça eh bien il
faut bien trouver un acheteur et que
l'acheteur aujourd'hui c'est qui c'est
la banque centrale pierre abanda vous
parliez un lancement de d'économie
réelle concrètement justement si la fed
ferment le robinet quelles seront les
conséquences sur cette économie réelle
ben c'est tout le paradoxe de la
situation en fait mais qui remonte à
quai qui remonte aux années 2000 qui
remonte à la bulle internet on a une
déco nax une déconnexion entre le marché
réel et le marché financier et qui crée
une relation qui est complètement
asymétrique si les marchés financiers
vont bien ça tape ça n'apporte pas
particulièrement pas obligatoirement un
bien-être supplémentaire ou une relance
dans l'économie réelle en revanche s'ils
vont pas bien et s'il s'effondre ça a un
impact négatif sur le marché réel
donc on est dans une situation qui est
un peu un peu bizarre où finalement le
marché financier gère un peu le jeu
économique où les politiques économiques
et sa bénéficie pas forcément marché
réel là dans ce cas ci on arrête tout
d'un coup si vous avez des bulls et une
explosion d'une bulle c'est de l'argent
qui ne disparaît et donc bon bah quand
c'est de l'argent de deux gros fonds qui
ont spéculé qu'ils utilisent ou qui ont
investit d'ailleurs mais qui utilise de
l'argent uniquement des noms fictifs ou
de la planche à billets c'est pas grave
sauf que dans le paquet vous avez aussi
des gens comme vous et moi qui pouvait
avoir des assurances vie qui peut avoir
simplement placé de l'argent ou
simplement déposer à la banque est donc
là si les bulles explosent vous aussi
vous vous retrouvez pauvre et c'est
d'autant plus grave pour les pour les
petits ménages parce que lorsque vous
avez ou pour les ménages les plus
pauvres ou les plus modestes parce que
lorsque vous avez une explosion de
bulles comme ça et que il faut
reconstruire et qui a plus d'argent
notamment pour des états surendettés
d'abord les impôts restent les mêmes ou
augmentent et en même temps vous n'avez
pas les moyens de vous refaire quand le
marché repart parce que vous n'avez pas
investi sur les marchés financiers donc
ceux qui gagnent ce sont ceux qui ont
beaucoup de patrimoine qu'ils ont mis
sur le marché financier au moment où ça
repart alors que ceux qui perdent c'est
ce qu'ils disent simplement payer des
impôts et qui n'ont pas les moyens de
nous qui n'ont pas ou qui n'ont pas eu
la cette attirance au départ pour le mas
le marché financier donc l'explosion
d'une bulle va être néfaste pour le
marché réel et principalement pour les
ménages les plus pauvres d'où la
l'impossibilité en fait de couper les
robinets mais aussi la peur de continuer
de continuer dans cette stratégie parce
que à terme vous avez simplement des
risques inflationnistes qui sont très
forts et là aussi des risques
inflationnistes
ben en fait ça pénalise les gens qui ont
les comportements les moins risqués les
gens qui ont placé un petit peu d'argent
à la banque où les gens qui gagnent
simplement leur salaire et qui n'ont pas
pu mettre en place des projets de
d'endettement très fort donc ils sont en
fait vous punissez les fourmis vous
récompenser les cigales qui ont pris le
plus de risques
et c'est le moment de marquer une courte
pause on se retrouve à juste après
est de retour dans ces casses si vous
nous rejoignez émission toujours
consacré aux annonces de la fed fermera
tel le robinet quand le peut-elle
vraiment réponse avec olivier delamarche
toujours est notre invité pierre bentata
économiste et président du cabinet rl
zen alors voici un extrait un de ces
minutes de la fed si l'économie évolué
comme prévu il pourrait être approprié
de commencer à réduire le rythme des
achats d'actifs cette année pierre à
bentata on sent quand même de la
prudence
oui c'est ce que je vous disais c'est
les économistes dans ce cas là se
mettent tous à aller vraiment faire de
l'analyse sur qu'est-ce que signifie
chaque mot pourquoi cela est il utilisé
au conditionnel et là on voit bien qu'en
fait on vous dit bon si tout se passe
comme prévu que tout va bien et que
finalement nos modèles sont vraies et
que par miracle il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas trop de problèmes on va diminuer
mais vous voyez bien vous avez du
conditionnel on pourrait commencer à
réduire le rythme des achats donc ça
veut pas dire qu'on va arrêter non plus
en fait c'est simplement une mise en
garde en disant voilà on s'aperçoit que
ce qu'on craignait est en train
d'arriver pendant longtemps on nous a
dit non non l'inflation ça n'existe plus
il n'y a plus aucun souci toute la
théorie monétaire est faux ce qui nous
dit que une augmentation de la masse
monétaire se traduit par de l'inflation
bon on s'aperçoit que finalement la cia
il ya un petit retour de cette vision
orthodoxe de l'économie et qu' il va
falloir le prendre en considération
parce que une crise inflationniste c'est
un vrai problème pour une économie on
sait on sait pas comment on sort
lorsqu'on a une super inflation sais pas
comment on en sort sans causer des
dégâts importants donc ici c'est une
façon de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé en
disant on va continuer on va continuer
évidemment à soutenir l'économie
financière mais attention il ya un
problème oui olivier à prudence pour
certains vous dirais plutôt que
finalement la fed est coincé la fille la
fed et est réellement coincé c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui le moi je ne crois
pas du tout à une résurgence
massive de l'inflation pourquoi parce
que ça voudrait dire qu'il ya de
l'activité en fait c'est quoi à
l'inflation au départ c'est quoi
l'inflation c'est le le temps que met
la l'offre pour s'ajuster à une demande
qui arrive comme ça et qui est forte or
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas la demande
n'est pas forte et secundo vous êtes à
des taux d'utilisation des capacités qui
est à autour de 70% donc on est loin de
d'avoir un décalage dans le temps on est
loin d'être obligé de construire des
usines pour s'adapter à la demande en
plus on a encore plein d'usiné zombies
qui créent de des surcapacités qui font
que on est on est loin de ce problème là
donc l'inflation dite classique
elle est pas là il ya une inflation qui
est qui est dû à la banque centrale
l'apurement sur des matières premières
par exemple sur de l'énergie c'est à
dire que vous mettez de l'argent les
banques à défaut de jouer sur les
marchés actions ou les marchés
obligataires qu'est ce qu'elles vont
faire elles vont aussi jouer sur les
marchés de matières premières vous avez
je donne l'exemple assez souvent vous
avez le sucre qui a pris 100 % je suis
pas sûr qu'on mange plus de sucre 1
qu'avant donc le le problème n'est pas
là c'est simplement les marchés
financiers qui sur les actifs financiers
à reese et dont l'immobilier par exemple
se mettre dessus et donc joue dessus et
donc ça cette inflation là elle existe
et puis on a une troisième mais qui là
est vraiment
dû à ce qui s'est passé duo que vive etc
c'est une inflation de je dirais de
désorganisation des circuits productifs
et des circuits de consommation il est
clair vous avez vu il ya quelques il ya
quelques jours qu'on a annoncé qu' un
des principal port chinois étaient
bloqués parce qu'il ya eu un un foyer
d'infection de dents dont ils bloquent
le port évidemment il n'y a plus aucune
marchandise qui rentre ou qui sort
évidemment ça fait monter les prix
forcément donc si vous voulez le
il ya sept ça mais ça c'est c'est
passager je dirais c'est à dire tant qu'
on gère les choses comme ça tant que
pour un gars qui a eu un pc erne positif
on bloque absolument tout évidemment ça
va créer des désorganisations et ça va
créer de l'inflation mais l'inflation la
vraie celle qui provient d'un surcroît
d'activité faut pas se du monde
aujourd'hui on est loin d'être à 100 %
des capacités et on est loin d'avoir une
tension qui est dû à ça donc l'attention
elle est principalement due à ce que
fait la banque centrale et c'est pour ça
qu'elle a qu entre deux chaises c'est à
dire que lé d'un côté elle voudrait bien
pouvoir arrêter parce qu'elle sait que
là on va pouvoir avoir de
l'hyperinflation qui n'a rien à voir
avec l'inflation autres s'ils voulaient
qui est juste une descente aux enfers de
la monnaie et donc elle sait que ça va
se terminer comme ça sauf que si elle
arrête aujourd'hui de faire tourner la
planche à billets et bien le les marchés
financier s'écroule et ça va pas
l'arranger oui les marchés financier
s'écroule injustement va regarder les
indices boursiers ensuite aux annonces
de la fed en ait eu moins 1% pour le dow
jones pareil pour le nasdaq et -2 points
49 % pour le cac 40 pierre bentata on le
voit un les marchés financiers se sont
appuyés sur les largesses de la banque
centrale si elles ferment le robinet les
marchés menacent de s'écrouler comment
appréciez vous le fait que les deux
soient autant dépendants
mais c'est
encore une fois c'est parce qu'on a eu
on a une économie financière qui est qui
vit vraiment sous perfusion et c'est ce
et c'est en grande partie le résultat de
la façon qu'on a eus d'éviter les
différentes crises financières ou les
différentes explosions de bulles des 20
dernières années mais c'est
le vrai problème là dedans c'est que
justement olivier parler d'eux si on a
une inflation disons traditionnel avec
une demande qui est supérieure à l'offre
mais ça à la limite ça se gère on sait
qu'il faut un détour ils font un détour
de production il faut des
investissements le problème c'est que
ici toute l'économie de marché elle est
déréglée
justement parce que vous avez une
inflation qui une inflation qui arrive
alors que vous avez une activité faible
et ça c'est ça c'est le vrai problème
est donc sur la fed enfin où toutes les
banques centrales de toute façon sont
bloqués
j'ai pas de doute sur le génie de des
gens qui travaillent dans les banques
centrales et le gène et des
gouvernements moi j'étais assez
sceptique sur la façon que la france
allait par exemple a eu de soutenir
l'activité puis on voit que on a réussi
à amortir le choc donc j'ai pas je ne
vais pas la crainte d'un effondrement de
des marchés financiers comme ça du jour
au lendemain le problème par contre
c'est comment on comment on revient à
une situation qui est saine parce que là
la situation d'un point de vue
économique est vraiment malsaines c'est
très difficile de savoir qu'il va bien
et qu'il va pas structurellement en fait
les tous les signaux sont brouillées
parce que chaque fois qu un secteur un
problème chaque fois que le marché
financier va pas bien on remet au pot et
que donc estimer la vraie valeur d'une
activité estimé est-ce qu'on crée de la
valeur ou pas est-ce qu'on gaspille des
ressources ou est-ce qu'au contraire on
améliore leur rendement et leur
rentabilité
ça c'est quelque chose qui devient
quasiment impossible et la vraie
question là dedans c'est donc on sait
jouer à court terme pour essayer de
trouver une nouvelle idée un nouveau
truc un nouvel instrument qui va
continuer à soutenir le système mais
comment on fait pour un moyen terme ou à
long terme avoir un nouveau une
situation qui est saine et sans laquelle
c'est très dur d'avoir une vraie
croissance des vraies innovations
ça c'est pour moi la vraie question
parce que maintenant on a du coup ce
système hybride où tout le monde est
pieds et poings liés c'est une sorte de
jeu de dupes où tout le monde sans dette
et se prête et quand on est dans cette
situation c'est
enfin moi en tout cas j'ai pas de
solution pour en sortir j'ai
l'impression que l'économie mondiale se
à nice d'une certaine façon et je je
ne sais pas comment les banques
centrales doivent sortir de ça olivier
finalement ce que les banques centrales
se sont bien armé face à la pandémie est
ce qu'elle avait autrefois trop
stratégique au d'augmenter ainsi l'achat
d'actifs alors attention je vous ai dit
le plusieurs fois pour moi là la
pandémie est un accélérateur est un
détonateur mais ces pâles c'est pas le
noeud du problème
le noeud du problème il remonte à avant
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit vous l'avais
dit en dix ans et c'est une politique
qu'on mène depuis 2000 en fait depuis 20
ans et c'est réellement ça c'est à dire
que pendant 20 ans on a en fait et puis
plus récemment pendant les 13 dernières
années depuis 2008 où on a fortement
accéléré les choses mais on a on a
constitué un système qui finalement ne
marche ne fonctionne que sur la dette
puisqu'il ya plus de je dirais de il ya
plus d'argent frais il ya plus de sap
fonctionne uniquement sur la dette et
pour soutenir cette dette pour que cette
dette puisse être produites et bah
qu'est ce qu'on fait on demande à la
banque centrale va imprimer des billets
et donc elle imprime des billets elle
achète cette dette est en fait c'est un
espèce de circuit fermé de serpent qui
se mord la queue si vous voulez et est
en permanence aujourd'hui comme les
états ont besoin de plus d'argent pour
entretenir une espèce d'illusion de
croissance se situent ça n'est jamais
qu'une illusion de croissance si vous
mettez à chaque fois 10 de dettes pour
avoir un de chiffre d'affaires ça marche
pas ça ne fonctionne pas et aujourd'hui
on c'est encore pire on essaie de
remplacer de l'activité
c'est à dire du chiffre d'affaires du
pib par de la dette
cc c'est c'est inconcevable normalement
en économie n'importe quel chef
d'entreprise vous lui dites ça il vas y
vas y vas ticket un peu hein il va avoir
des soucis et bien là on fait ça au
niveau des états et on ne fait plus que
ça et donc aujourd'hui
le banquier central finalement c'est
devenu le celui qui fournit qui imprime
c'est un imprimeur c'est un imprimeur et
c'est que ça c'est à dire qu' il n'a pas
d'autres pouvoirs que ça d'ailleurs on
lui dit bon son
dans ses statuts normalement ils étaient
là pour contrôler les taux d'intérêt et
donc a priori pour éviter qu'ils aient
des période inflationniste est haute et
là c'est plus doux tout ça aujourd'hui
il doit soutenir les marchés c'est son
unique but il doit absolument soutenir
les marchés et il doit fournir de
l'argent pour que le gouvernement
puissent s'endetter c'est tout là on a
on a complètement changé pour les
banques centrales les les buts les
statuts lalala le skull ce qu'ils
devaient faire leurs actes ont
complètement changé et et ça et depuis
depuis 2008 de même depuis 2000 est donc
aujourd'hui on est en train d'en payer
les conséquences
le coville n'a absolument pas changé il
a appuyé un peu plus sur les choses et
il a augmenté la vitesse des choses
c'est tout mais mais il n'est pas
responsable le virus n'a jamais demandé
le du quantitative easing et c'est pas
en en mettant du quantitative easing
c'est à dire en injectant de la monnaie
que vous allez détruire le coronavirus
olivier merci c'est la fin de cette
deuxième partie notre invité bière
pierre bentata économiste et directeur
de cabinet par une zone merci pour votre
éclairage on se retrouve tout de suite
merci pierre
troisième et dernière partie de cette
émission avec non plus les questions
cash mais les commentaires cachent les
commentaires internet de nos
téléspectateurs concernant la précédente
émission s'était consacré la chute de la
natalité avec l'invité essayiste antoine
bueno et on va commencer par be bop 25
qui nous dit qu heureusement aucun
politique n'évoque ce problème alors que
la pérennité d'une retraite par
répartition nécessite un taux de
natalité supérieur à deux naissances par
couple olivier on peut dire que c'est
une remarque judicieusement ah oui tout
à fait on l'a on l'a dit le taux de
renouvellement le taux de fécondité
minimum c'était de 10
et on est loin en dessous dans tous les
pays européens aux etats-unis aussi au
japon aussi en chine aussi donc dans
l'essentiel des pays du monde sauf le
seul qui est une croissance de sa
natalité c'est l'afrique mais mise à
part ça tout le reste est encore c'est
très disparates en afrique tout le reste
de lait des continents sont touchés par
ça et on est touché on est on est à des
taux de fécondité qui sont très très en
dessous c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas un
90 ou à deux on est
maintenant alors on n'a pas les derniers
chiffres depuis le coc vide mais on sait
que ça s'est effondré sur sur quelques
mois donc on sait qu en espagne en
italie on va être plutôt autour de 1,10
1,15 peut-être et en france on va
probablement descendre autour de 1,60
on était à 1 84 avant le avant le le coc
vide donc voilà on sait que ça va très
mal se passer parce que en plus de ça
aujourd'hui on a une population donc qui
vieillit et on va se retrouver avec un
taux de dépendance qui va être proche de
1 rapidement et proche de 1 ça veut dire
que vous avez un actif pour indépendants
et que là les problèmes commencent merci
olivier merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis c'est donc la fin de cette
émission mission à retrouver sur notre
site rt france point tv et n'hésitez pas
à laisser des commentaires je vous dis à
bientôt la semaine prochaine vous
retrouverez estelle fare les oliviers je
vous laisse le mot de la fin
revient à écouter en matière de banque
centrale communication n'est pas action